I'm in Brixton prison trying to make a success out of my bad boy's bakery
My Kitchen team have complained they're getting grief from the officers but the officers themselves have got a different version of events
A couple of them think their superstars calling me all names and there's some like pussyhole and God knows what?
I'm finding it incredibly frustrating getting the prison kitchen up and running and I'm not in the mood for any backchat.
And the officers aren't the only ones giving me a hard time
Yeah, right, you know the procedure
No trust, none at all
Really if there's trust they can leave it open do you know what I mean? Even when they take a piss.
What I need are team players
Convicted burglar. Renny Smith is a good cook, but sometimes he's more interested in cleaning up
That's how I am I see something so I'm just naturally like I don't know if I've got OCD or whatever they call it.
That's my upbringing you make sure you got clean boxes every day and number two you make sure you make your bed.
OCD or not. Rene can be a real handful. It's not his first time inside
But I'll never come back to this place never
I hate it.
That's how the real world is.
All of you come over, let's go
Kiev's done, I need to check everyone's handiwork. Lots of parsley, very good. Do you taste the butter?
No, whose is this one? Nor, that's all that waterfall. He didn't put the water from the carrots on there, did you?
Really? Cheers for that. Let me finish my fucking job. Look at me. You're trying to be funny?
Nor: No n-
Gordon: Cheers for that?!
The last thing I need today is Ramsy busting my balls about a bit of cooking juice on a tiny work surface.
But when I'm in the middle of a conversation and you rudely interrupt me and say "Cheers to that Gordon." like you own the fucking stove. Do you?!
I don't own the fucking stove.
No? Then don't talk like it's yours only then I'm getting sick and tired of all this petty bullshit you guys like the growing man
You have an amazing opportunity here knuckle down and do something and if you don't want to do that then go back to yourself
Renee has taken me at my word and warp
This team that pull that fucking shut up there are things with four bits, I mean they all love it
y'all ain't gonna get nowhere and
Johnny's got to keep us on our toes because you know what we fuckin prisoners
We are going to cut corners here and there so I mean what your s what we're that's what we know
It's hard very very hard I've been holding back
since I got in here, I mean really holding back so
How many times they need to cross you before you you're gonna go for it? And so yeah, yes, there's areas. I'm struggling
With a pressure I'm under I've overreacted I don't want to lose a good cook like Renee serve ask for a sit-down
Exactly, how are you?
Yeah, yeah quick two minutes. Yeah, that's why I tell you something really important. Yeah, okay, you're in prison
Yeah, I'm in prison to do a job. Right? Yeah and
Yeah, I snapped but here's what I want to say when you work and you put that effort in you shine
I think it might have come out wrong, which I put my hands up to that
As I said, you know what Cora, I'm sorry, ain't it? I know I can say it and you know, I'm not closing the door
understand
Don't throw away. No, all I can say good. I'm sorry. I'm so so for you wasting your time for coming over here
I'll see you Monday morning
Appreciate and I'll catch up on my work Monday morning. Appreciate ya. Thank you, Hey
In future, whatever the reason I can't allow any kind of dissent from my team
from now on
Anyone that walks out?
stays out
Just like that steak you cooked gordon